back in the day when i picked up the
game of football
and when mixtapes was big one day i was
out in practice and he was kind of just
doing different moves and i said you
know what i'm gonna start spinning i'm
gonna start drop step i'm gonna do this
type of thing in football see if it
works
sure enough i was making people miss
[Music]
the wife but you know it's different
times now it's different
how are you living here in right now
we're tied so it was easy
you know you said i'm not doing much
it's definitely insane
[Music]
you are a legend upstate you played at
syracuse i grew up in texas i was big
12th country okay
i didn't watch too much big east
football yeah but when vic was on
people was watching yeah do you have a
memorable story at all
during your time playing against vic
virginia tech cubes big east football
oh absolutely i mean mike vick we laugh
about it now my junior year
when we played them in the carrier dome
it happened to be my best
individual game of my entire career
high school college pro best game best
game ever
i don't know what came over me man it
got to a point where the ball would snap
in slow motion
you know i would already be moving and
the ball's moving and that offensive
tackle still in the stance he can't even
move
i'm like three steps past him mike ain't
have a chance that game man how crazy
was it what numbers did you put up in
that game that made it
i had four and a half sacks could have
probably had six sacks that game so i
was on a whole nother planet that game
but in the end that game was probably my
most
memorable game for one reason having a
great game
but the second reason is i ended up
getting
hurt in that game you got hurt i got
hurt
hitting him what happened he ducked
one particular play his helmet
hit me right here in my abdomen i
ended up having a lacerated spleen
from that situation so i get hurt by
hitting a quarterback uh
the other way around so yeah exactly so
now you know that builds up my hatred
for quarterbacks even more you know what
i'm saying now
i can't hit y'all y'all hurt me so now i
can't have that you played with a
lacerated spleen did you know that
during the game
no listen i played the rest of the game
didn't know
i had a lacerated spleen we played on
saturdays
on monday i woke up everything was in
slow motion
my eyes was blurry i couldn't even
function skin was popping
all types of stuff was happening to me
the trainers
they didn't know what was wrong with me
so they had to quarantine me i was like
the force guy to get quarantined
they did all types of different studies
on me and they found out the cat scans
that i was bleeding internally they
start giving me
antibiotics i ended up being allergic to
the penicillin so now all of a sudden i
got this lacerated spleen i'm taking
medicine i'm allergic to my skin is
breaking out all types of great stuff
just bleeding internally
being interning just behind the
quarterback right
it's crazy so how did it all get
resolved i mean you said you're dealing
with this for a couple weeks
you're still playing i'm a rap for the
rest of the year i'm done
i'm done done done i ended up losing 30
40 pounds that junior year 30 40 pounds
it was crazy man i looked i
looked sick i was like 250 something to
like 215.
i thought i was on my way i thought your
career was done done the rest of the
year
i was done ended up coming back in
spring football got my weight back up
and that was it
how the hell do you put back 40 pounds
hey i started eating
sorry i'm jamaican
that's crazy to think that your career
could have ended before you even started
professionals oh
how do you block that out i mean your
whole job is to hit the quarterback so
every single time you're rushing the
quarterback is that on your mind
well i have a hatred for quarterbacks
and you're supposed to have a hatred for
quarterbacks if you're a guy who's going
after him
when the jets win the afc championship
2009 2000 they ended up playing us this
is when these rules start coming out
which destroyed me which even gave me
more fuel to hate him it's a strike zone
fourth quarter we up two scores i'm
going out
running around the corner it's a screen
pass i got sanchez
lined up to completely just wipe him out
i can't imagine
something goes through my head saying
you know what don't hit the quarterback
it's close you might get a penalty
you might hurt the guy i jump over him
do a little
turn just so i don't hit him you avoid a
quarterback i avoided him when i land
he rolls on my ankle completely
severs the ligaments in my ankle i have
a third
degree high ankle spray just because i'm
trying to
avoid hitting a quarterback now i'm
supposed to be out four to six weeks
the super bowl's in two weeks i mean you
probably lost super bowl because i was
hurt
never again am i gonna avoid a
quarterback if i see one right now
i'm not getting my little yeah no
quarterbacks on set dude
quarterbacks no
all right cool so what do you think of
mark sanchez's name now dude let me see
mark said
okay remember that time i avoided you
when i had that high ankle spray
i'm gonna give him a little four off
sugar something something
we ended up losing that super bowl and
i'm still upset about that is that the
saints
yeah to the saints i don't like talking
about them
say less
you